[موسيقى]
ترحيب خاصه بكل مشاهدينا في كل مكان وضيوف
البرنامج الذي تشاهدونهم على الشاشه
ويمكنكم ان تتفاعلوا مع ما يقولون على
صفحتنا على فيسبوك او على صفحه البرنامج
على تويتر
الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حتى نتحدث
عن التباين في المقاربه الامريكيه
والاوروبيه للحرب في اوكرانيا على
الاقتصاد القاره العجوز حرب تتسبب في ازمه
الطاقه خاصه مع دخول فصل الشتاء سعر الغاز
هو اغلى خمس مرات مما هو عليه في الولايات
المتحده جغرافيا واقتصاديا اوروبا هي التي
تدفع ثمن ذلك انه في زمن الشده فان واشنطن
تفكر في مصالح شركه ووضعت خطه لدعم بل
وحتى لجلب شركه اوروبيه تستثمر في امريكا
هذا ناهيكا عن طريقه روسيا التي تريد ان
تحتر مفهوم القيم رغم كل ما ترتكبه من
دهسن لسياده اوكرانيا من خلال قصر متواصل
للمدن وضربا للبيئه التحت فهل فعلا
المصالح تظل دائما فوق الصدقات مثل ما كان
يقول وما هي القواسم المشتركه بين امريكا
واوروبا في الازمه الاوكرانيه سعيد
بانناقش الموضوع ما ينافس الاستديو حسن
عبيدي استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
جنيف سعيد بان يكون معنا من برلين شابيرما
ياسين وهو كاتب وصحفي مختصه بشؤون
الاوروبيه وسعيده بان يكون معنا من واشنطن
ابراهيم الاصيل كبير الباحثين في معهد
الشرق الاوسط في واشنطن اهلا وسهلا بكم
قبل ان نبدا نستمع لما قاله جون كيري
حيوي اقدم حليفا للولايات المتحده تمتدوا
علاقتنا الاقتصاديه في قطاعات متطوره مع
استثمارات كبيره في كلا الاتجاهين يستمر
تعاوننا الدفاع والامن في التوسع وهو امر
حيوي للسلام والاستقرار في العالم
ابراهيم الاصيل
واضح في المصالح بين اوروبا
والولايات المتحده خاصه في ظل هذه
القرارات التي اتخذها بايدا ومع ذلك
المظهر الخارجي انه يوجد توافق ولكن
الواقع يختلف عن ذلك
مرحبا بكم بالضيوف الكرام هناك طبعا
الكثير من العوامل المشتركه بين البلدين
وهناك الكثير من نقط الاختلاف ايضا ولكن
لا ارى بان العوامل التي يختلف عليها
الطرفان اكثر من العوامل التي يتفق عليها
هناك بعض الاختلافات طبعا في اسلوب
المواجهه هناك بعض الاختلافات في موضوع
متى يجب ان تحاول اوكرانيا التفاوض مع
الطرف الروسي في النزاحه لاوكرانيا
بالاضافه لبعض الاختلافات في المواضيع
الاقتصاديه في مواضيع القوانين التي مررها
بايضا وفيها دعم للكثير من المنتجات
الامريكيه التي يشعر الطرف الفرنسي بانها
فيها شيء من الحمائيه الاقتصاديه التي يجب
ان لا تكون ضمن الاسس الاقتصاديه خصوصا
بين الطرفين على المحيطين الاطلسي الطرف
الامريكي والطرف الفرنسي ولكن هذه الزياره
مهمه جدا لانها الزياره الاولى على مستوى
الدوله واختار بيضا بوضوح على ان تكون مع
فريق الفرنسي نظرا لاهميه فرنسا الان ضمن
القاره الاوروبيه واضافي العلاقات مع
الصين المملكه المتحده من جهه تراجع دورها
العالمي وكذلك المانيا بعد رحيل المستشاره
ميركل لم تعد تتمتع بصفه القياديه والموقع
القوي الذي عهدناه تحت قياده مريكو وهذا
يشكل فرصه كبيره لمكرون وفرنسا لان تقوم
بهذا الدور الكبير ولذلك جاءت هذه الزياره
ولذلك جاءت هذه المواضيع لمناقشه هذه
الاختلافات ولمعرفه تماما ما الذي يختلف
عليها الطرفين وما الذي يتفق عليها
الطرفين في محاوله لوضع خطه للسنوات
القادمه حسنا الخلافات قائمه ولكن اوروبا
حتى الان هي التي تدفع ثمن تداعيات العرب
في اوكرانيا على عكس الولايات المتحده
يعني
الخلافات مهمه جدا يعني ما سمعناه هيدلوا
على اساس انه الخلافات يعني اكبر جدا من
اوجه الاتفاق يعني قضايا الاقتصاديه ليست
الولايات المتحده في شهر ثمانيه الولايات
المتحده وافقت على اكثر 230 مليار دولار
من اجل حمايه الاقتصاد الامريكي والتشجيع
الشركات التي تشجع في النهايه ما يسمى
بالانتقال الانتقال البيئي
وان يكون اكثر من 75% من مكونات السيارات
مصنوعه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يعني سيارات كهربائيه يعني هذه ضربه قاسيه
لكل شركه تصنيع السيارات الاوروبيه وحتى
الامريكيه التي كانت تريد ان تستثمر في
اوروبا با الاف من المناصب الشغل
مفوضيه رئيس المفوضيه كان في البدايه كانت
يعني يعني رحبت بهذا القرار لكن المفوض
الاوروبي قال لها يعني هذه مشكله كبرنا
الاقتصاد الاوروبي وكان تهديد اصلا بحتى
الذهاب الى منظمه صار العالم ورفع الدعوه
ضد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بان هذا
مخالف لقوانين التجاره الحره لمنظمه
التجاره العالمي فن اعتقد ان الخلافات
عميقه جدا لكن الغرب هو كذا يعني الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تريد ان تتجاوز هذه
القضيه راي ذلك في قضيه الغواصات مع فرنسا
والرئيس ماكرون كذلك يريد هذا الدور
الدولي الذي هناك يعني نافذه مفتوحه ويريد
استغلالها لكن انا اؤكد ان الخلافات
اقتصاديه مهمه مهمه جدا ومن الصعب جدا على
الرئيس بيادر قبل كل شيء ان يخالف خاصه
الغرفه ستكون جمهوريه ويتراجع عن هذا
الموضوع وبالنسبه كذلك الدول الاوروبيه من
الصعب ان تقبل بان تكون الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الافضل قبل كل شيء في شركاتها
وبان يباع لهم الغاز اربع ايام
كما يباع للشركات الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه فن اعتقد سنصل بعد ربما نوع من
الحساسيه مع همم روسيا كذلك الى حساسيه مع
الولايات المتحده نتيجه العام الاقتصادي
الفرمه خاصه في في المانيا يعني المانيا
هي التي ان في موقف يعني صعب جدا لانها من
بين الدول التي بالفعل تدفع ضريبه ما يجري
في اوكرانيا
صحيح تحياتي لك ولظيفك ولجميع مشاهديك
قناه فرنسبنكات الخلافات عميقه ما بين
الاتحاد الاوروبي وما بين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الخلافات عميقه ما بين
فرنسا بشكل خاص ما بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه زجلت بالاتحاد الاوروبي باكمله
في حرب
له فيها ولا جمل امام الدب الروسي حرمت
الاقتصاد الالماني من الغاز الروسي الرخيص
الذي كان الرئيس الاساسيه لاصناعات سواء
كان في المانيا او في ايطاليا وفي اسبانيا
او في فرنسا هناك نقاط خلاف كبيره ما بين
الوحدات والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وفرنسا البدايه من عهد ترامب حيث قال ان
امريكا اولا وبيض يقول امريكا بشكل مخفي
نحن نتحدث عن صفقه الغواصات التي حرمت
فرنسا من 89 مليار يورو وهي اكبر صفقه
لفرنسا مع استراليا ابعدت فرنسا عن هذا
التحالف الثلاثي في المحيط الهادي
التحالف البريطاني الامريكي الاسترالي ضد
الصين ايضا هناك مناوشات امريكيه فرنسيه
داخل القاره السمراء هناك ايضا مشاكل ما
بين فرنسا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبشكل عامه بين الاتحاد الاوروبي ما يسمى
بقانون حفظ خفض التضخم والذي ستكتوي به
الصناعات الفرنسيه والالمانيه هناك اسعار
غاز عاليه تباع للاتحاد الاوروبي سواء
كانت من العم سام او من النرويج نحن نتحدث
عن تضخم عالي في الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي
فتره الوقود اقتصادي الخلافات عميقه ما
بين الجهتين لا اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مستعده لارضاء الطرف الاوروبي
والارضاء الطرف الفرنسي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يهمها الداخليه ال- ال- الداخل
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في الدرجه
الاولى وما اقرار هذا القانون وهو خفض
التضخم الاضاءه الناخب الامريكي وانجراء
هذه الانتخابات
وصحيح لكنه لم يسجل بها في عفوا اوروبا لم
يزج بها في السيره يعني حتى نعترف نقول
الحقيقه يعني هناك هناك خيارات اوروبيه
يعني كان ممكن اوروبا ان تقول لا
نتبعيه من قبل الدول الاوروبيه الدول
الاوروبيه صحيح ولكن من من الذي كان وراء
السيل الشمالي اثنين من عهد ترامب وحتى هم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كانت هناك رفض
كامل لامداد هذا الخط والاستقبال الاتحاد
الاوروبي لهذا الغاز همم الاتحاد الدب
الروسي استولى على شبه جزيره القيم في عام
2014 ولم يتحرك الاتحاد الاوروبي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وباقي الحال
على ما هو عليه لا لا اتحدث عن الولايات
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يجب ان يكون مكتوفا
لايدي امام الاعتداء الروسي على اوكرانيا
ولكن هناك مصالح اقتصاديه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ترى لمصالحها
الاقتصاديه
في ذلك ان هناك تخفيض 15% على ضرائب
الشركات الشركات التي تصنع السيارات وهذا
شيء مدمر لشركات التي تصنع في المانيا وفي
فرنسا هناك ايضا همم
بان انت انت في اوروبا يعني الدول
الاوروبيه اصلا للاسف يعني ليست متفقه على
نفس المقاربه مع الولايات المتحده هناك
دول تقول بان هذا الاتفاق الذي صوت عليه
صوت عليه دار الامريكيه هو مضر سنه
اوروبيه لكن في النهايه ضرر هو متجانس
هناك دول اوروبيه بعض الدول الشماليه تقول
احنا لا نريد فتح جبها مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والان نحن الان في قضيه
مهمه جدا وهي امننا مهدد خاصه مع تعدي
روسيا على على التراب الاوروبي باعتبار ان
اوكرانيا امتداد لهذا الامن همم الاوروبي
وروسيا ايضا هي من القاره الاوروبيه لا
ننسى ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والغرب اوروبا لم يمنحوا الضمانات الامنيه
التي يريدها روسيا حتى لا تدخل اوكرانيا
ضمن الحلف الناتو نحن نحن هناك معاهدات ما
بين الرئيس جربه عندما قال انه لن يكون
هناك اي توسع لحلف الناتو شرقا جميع دول
حلف النيه والان تسيطر على اوروبا الشرقيه
باستثناء بلا روسيا اوكرانيا وجورجيا
وروسيا اي ان الاتحاد حلف الناتو اراد
جميع ان تنظم وهناك في التهديد الاول في
حلف الناتو هو روسيا تعتبر العدو الاول
ومن ثم كوريا والصين اذا عندما تسمى حلف
ان نيته عندما يسمى روسيا بانه العدو
الاول يحق لي روسي ان لا ترغب في وجود في
الحديقه الخلفيه اوكرانيا او بلا روسيا او
جورج ادخاله الى حلته المشكله جيو سياسيه
ولكن المشكله الاقتصاديه التي ضغط على
اوروبا هي عدم تمكنها او هي اعتمادها بشكل
كبير جدا على الغاز الروسي والنفط الروسي
لمده اكثر من 20 سنه ليس هو رئيس من الامس
ولا قبل الامس حتى تتحدث عنه انه رئيس
ديكتاتوري الرئيس ليست ديكتاتوريه همم
الرئيس الروسي منذ عام 2000 وهو في سته
الحكم حتى بعد كان هو رئيس الوزراء اي ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي لا ينظر الى حقوق
الانسان عندما كان الغاز ياتي برخص التراب
وكاله المصانع الالمانيه والمصانع
الاوروبيه تتحرك وتدور طيب يا ابراهيم همم
الاصيل
يعني يعني بدايه هناك عدد من النقط التي
نناقشها هنا في البدايه كنا نناقش هل سجد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بالاتحاد
الاوروبي في الحرب ضد روسيا هذا امر خاطئ
هذه حقيقه وليس امر تابع للراي روسيا غزوه
اوكرانيا روسيا بدات حربا بدون اي استفزاز
حرب خارقه لكل القوانين والاعراف الدوليه
دخلت الى اوكرانيا ارتكبت جرائم حاول
التغيير ترسيم الحدود الذي كانت ثابته
لعقود طويله ومن ثم لم يكن هناك اي امام
الطرف الغربي سوى المواجهه اذا كنا ننتقد
الان الخيار الذي اتبعه المعسكر الغربي
علينا ان نقدم بديل ما الذي نقترحه هنا هل
نقترح بان يرحب الاتحاد الاوروبي بالغزو
الروسي ويقول طبعا بوتين كان رئيس لاكثر
من 20 عاما اذا يحق له بالاقدميه ان يغير
خريطه العالم هذا كلام لا اعتقد بانه من
الممكن ان نناقشه الان النقطه الاخرى ايضا
هي عندما نقول حلف الناتو قام بذلك
والمعسكر الغربي اذا نحن نقول وان قرد
امنيه بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وجراتها الاوروبيين متفقين على الخطوط
العريضه والعامه بخصوص امني ام القومي على
سبيل المثال موضوع مواجهه روسيا في
اوكرانيا لا يوجد اي اصوات بان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي من زوجته هذه الحرب
صحيح طبعا بان الدول الاوروبيه تتعرض
لخسائر اكبر لانها حرب على ارض اوروبيه
كما قال الزميل همم عندما قال با روسيا
اهي دوله اوروبيه بشكل ما اذا هذه حرب
داخل اوروبا
تقوم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ببيع
الغاز بثلاث اضعاف او اربع
اضعاف اوروبيه
ساكمل النقطه ساكمل النقطه ااه اذا هذه
الدول الاوروبيه اتخذت قرارها دعمتها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قامت بدور
قياده طبعا لان هذا هو التشكيل الامني بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه وقدمت الولايات
المتحده هي المالح الاكبر عسكريا وانسانيه
لاوكرانيا ايضا عندما نقول بان الولايات
المتحده لا تتحمل الخسائر كما اوروبا ما
هو المقترح هل هل المطلوب المزيد من الدعم
اذا ما قدمت واشنطن المزيد من الدعم هل
ستتهم بانها تقوم باشعال همم الصراع اكثر
مما هو عليه عندما ننتقد يجب ان نقدم بديل
لمعرفه
بشكل همم
بدانا نقرا العديد من نقلات في اوروبا
المشكله هي مس- حتى الان الان في حان
الكبير للولايات المتحده هي في مرحله
اعاده البناء لان حديثا اكثر من 1,000
مليار دولار لاعاده بناء اوكرانيا هل
ستساهم الولايات المتحده
مساهمه كبيره في ذلك ام ستترك اوروبا
تتصرف باعتبار من التداعيات تتحملها
اوروبا اكثر من الولايات المتحده وهذا هو
السؤال مطروح
لزملائي اعتقد ان هذه نقطه خلافيه اتفق
فيها مع الضيفين الكريمين هناك خلاف حول
مدى التزام الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
باعاده الاعمار في اوكرانيا ولكن حتى الان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي المانحه
الاكبر وبالتاكيد سيكون لديها اولويات في
موضوع المحيط الهادئ في الصراع مع الصين
ولكن تكلفه هذه الحرب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكن هذا اللون
يجب ان يقع على الطرف الروسي هو الطرف
الذي دمر اوكرانيا وليس الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هي صحيح يعني المشكله انه عندما
يتم الحديث عن البديل ولك قضيه همم
النافذه يعني السكن تراك الباب الثاني
وطريقه الثانيه والطريق الدبلوماسيه يعني
عندما ذهب او لا في الشغل لا اله الا الله
بيكين تم انتقاده داخل الولايات المتحده
وبعض الدول الاوروبيه الاكثر اطلسيه
ونعتقد حتى انه دعوه الرئيس رئيس رئيس
مكرون رئيس ماكرون ذكي يعني ترك زياره
للصين في العام المقبل لانه كان يريد قبل
كل شيء تتم زياره الولايات المتحده
المانيا وبالتالي من الصعب جدا الرئيس
الشغل
لدوله بريطانيا بريطانيا بعد خروجها من
البركست ثم انه عدم الاستقرار الان في
بريطانيا بقيت فرنسا هي الاكثر اكثر
ترشيحا فرنسا بدات ببعض المبادرات
الدبلوماسيه حتى من كانت
لدار الامريكيه لا تقبل بمساله الابقاء
على الحوار مع مع هذا ما اريد ان اقوله
يعني كم انتقاد الرئيس بقوه من قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبعض الدول
فلا اعتقد ان كذلك الولايات المتحده
مطالبه حلفاء القريبون جدا ان انتم تشجع
يعني ابقى على قناه الحوار بين بس مكروه
وبين رئيس بوتين حتى وان كانت ذكروه
الناطق الرسمي قالت في في مقاله قالت ان
الرئيس ان الرئيس همم ماكرون اتعبنا في في
في روسيا لانه يسر دائما على فتح هذه قناه
الاتصال فن اعتقد انه لابد من البقاء على
هذه القناه الدبلوماسيه وهذه الحرب لا
يمكن ان تتوقف الا بالحوار بالدبلوماسيه
طيب ضعيفه من برلين كنت اريد ان تتفاعل مع
ضيف من واشنط اتفضل
انا اساله سؤال لماذا تبيع الولايات
المتحده الغاز العجوز باربع اضعاف او خمسه
اضعاف او ثلاثه اضعاف حسب الدوله وتبيع
هذا الغاز داخل الامريكي باسعار رخيصه وهو
وهو شيء حائر لماذا تبيع الولايات المتحده
هؤلاء اصدقاء هؤلاء حلفاء للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ونتحدث عن اقتصاد السوق
صحيح بيع وطلب ولكن هؤلاء حلفاء يمكن ان
يتم بيع الدول الاوروبيه بنفس ال- بنفس
السعر الذي يبيع له الباين داخل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وهنا يظهر لماذا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي تلعب
لوحدها في الساحل العالميه هي لا ترى اي
دوله من الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي من انسحاب
ومن افغانستان الواحده لم تخبر الاتحاد
الاوروبي ما دخوله على الخط في افريقيا مع
دخولها على الخط في الغواصات الاستراليه
الا الى انها هي دوله وحيده تلعب بمفردها
ولا ترى ولا ترى في الاتحاد الاوروبي
اهميه كبيره هي تريد ان تخطب الشركات
الالمانيه والشركات الفرنسيه للذهاب متحده
الامريكيه لان سعر الغاز سعر الكهرباء
سيكون ارخص من الدخل الاتحاد الاوروبي هذه
الحرب التي زادت من نسبه التضخم زادت من
نسبه البطاله زبده من رزبه الركود
الاقتصادي بالاتحاد الاوروبي سببها صحيح
الاعتداء الروسي على بوتين ولكن سببها ان
العم سام اراد بها ارادها حرب استنزاف
اوروبيه روسيه ومن ثم الضرر الاقل على
العم سام في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
صحيح هي لوحدها لكن الحلف الاطلسي همم ليس
جمعيه خيريه يعني الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اكبر دوله مساهمه في الميزانيه
ويجب ان نستدرك في النهايات التاريخ
الاطلسي وفره مظله امنيه ويضل استراتيجيه
لاوروبا وكان احد اسباب الرفاع الاقتصادي
لانه كل يغتصب زياده اوروبيه يجب الاعتراف
بذلك يعني استثمر في التربيه والتعليم
والصحه لغير ذلك والولايات المتحده كانت
تدفع فاتوره الغطاء الامني والغطاء
العسكري وقالها الرئيس ترامب السابق قال
لابد على الدول الاوروبيه اعضاء الحفلات
الاطلسي ان تدفع كذلك فمن هذا الرفاه
الاقتصادي فما اعتقد هذه في النهايه محصله
لضعف اصلا لضعف العقيده العسكريه داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي ولذلك بدات الان في
اوروبا منذ الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه بدا
التفكير الان في ان تكون هناك استقلاليه
عسكريه للاتحاد الاوروبي حتى لا تخضع في
النهايه قضيه حمايه اوروبا من عدو خارجي
لان اوروبا لا يمكن لها اليوم انف ناي ان
توقف اي مد روسي على حدودها همم الشرقيه
لكن الشراكه هي ليست يعني البيع والشراء
ما بين ما بين اوروبا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
اذا ممكن
الغاز وموضوع التشاور مع الحلفاء في
النقطه الاولى موضوع الغاز الحكومه
الامريكيه لا تتحكم باسعار بياع الطاقه
داخل وخارج الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على عكس
الكثير من الدول لا تملك شركات النفط ولا
تتحكم ببيع الغاز وهذه يؤثر ليس فقط على
السوق الاوروبيه حتى على السوق الامريكيه
الكثير من الامريكيين يعترض لماذا يتم بيع
الغاز خارج امريكا والوقود في حين ان
الاسعار ترتفع لان ذلك يعود بشكل كامل الى
السوق ولا سلطه للحكومه الامريكيه على
الاطلاق على السوق همم النقطه الثانيه
بموضوع انسحاب الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
من افغانستان وعدم التشاور مع الحلفاء في
الكثير من الاحداث اتفق في الحقيقه بشكل
كبير همم في هذه النقطه نعم الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه خصوصا في عهد اوباما
وترامب تجاهلت الكثير من الشركاء حول
العالم ولم ترسل رسائل ايجابيه ولكن اعتقد
بان اداره بايدن بدات تتلافى هذا الموضوع
وبدات بمحاوله تحسين العلاقات مع حلفائها
وشركائها ضيف من برلين تفضل
ما اردت ان اضيفه ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تراعي مصالحها الداخليه
ومصالحها الجيو الاستراتيجيه يجبلي
المشكله في الاتحاد الاوروبي ان هناك
انقسام داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي سواء كان في
تحديد اسعار الغاز الان هناك مشاكل
ما بين الدول هناك دول البطيخ وبولندا
تريد ان تضع 30 دولار للبرميل الروسي هناك
دول مثل اليونان وايطاليا التي لديها
شركات كبيره همم لنقل النفط تريد ان ان
يكون هناك ما بين 65 الى 70 يورو هناك
انقسام ما بين الاتحاد الاوروبي ما بين
المانيا وفرنسا نذكر هذه الحزمه التي يمر
التي منحتها المانيا للشركات بقيمه همم
200 مليار يورو ولم يكن هناك اتفاق مع
فرنسا هناك الجيش الموحد الذي نادى به
المكون هناك المجموعه السياسيه التي تضم
جميع دول اوروبا تحت المظليتين واحده
باستثناء بلا روسيا وروسيا
اي ان هناك بعض الانقسام داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي واعتقد ان سبب هذا انقسام هو عدم
التنازج ما بين الفكر داخل فرنسا ما بين
ميكرون وما بين الرئيس والمستشار الالماني
الوفيتش لانه كان وقت ميركل هناك اكبر
اكثر تزاوج تماسجا ما بين الافكار
الفرنسيه الالمانيه التي هما الدولتين
التي تقوم عليهما الاتحاد الاوروبي يعني
هذه مشكله مشكله جديده تضاف الاتحاد
الاوروبي يعني صحيح
ان تكون همم المانيا ليس فقط قاطره قاطره
الاقتصاد الاوروبي رغم التعثر الحالي
وحاله الانتاج وليس ربما الركود همم لكن
تريد ان تكون كذلك المانيا في الواجهه
للاسف الحرب الاوكرانيه عدلت في النهايه
هذا المشروع والباقي بقي المجال فقط
لفرنسا
الدول النوويه ثم كذلك انها عضو مجلس
الامن واستفادت كذلك من تناقضات السياسه
السياسه الجديده لكن هذا لا يعني لا
يستثني الولايات المتحده الى حد الساعه
صرفت 65 مليار دولار اوكرانيا فقط منها 19
مليار بالتحديد فقط للاسلحه فيليب فيليه
اللي هو كما تعلم رئيس اركان العسكري
الجيش الفرنسي قال في اوروبا وفي فرنسا
ليس لدينا القدره الان ل ان تكون لدينا
دفاع مستقل يعني ان حتى العتاد والذخيره
لا تكفينا يكفي ان نرى الطائرات نقل نقل
القوه
[موسيقى]
كافيه اذا تعرضنا الى هجوم المطالبين
باعطاء المزيد من العتاد العسكرينيا
النقطه الثانيه ان الاسلحه نجيب ولا ننسى
هي يعني تشترك كذلك من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبتانا اعتقد من الولايات
المتحده اذا كانت لا تريد ان تتدخل في
اسعاره الغاز الصخري يمكن كذلك ان تقوم
بجهود في قضيه الاسلحه لانه الدول
الاوروبيه هي تشتري سلاح من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
لتعطيه لاوكرانيا هذه النقطه وبالتالي فهي
في نهايه تفقد نوع من قوتها العسكريه قوه
الرد العسكريه وفي نفس الوقت كذلك
الميزانيه العسكريه او الاقتصاد
الاقتصاديات الاوروبيه تتاثر من هذه
التكلفه العسكريه الاضافيه طيب ابراهيم
الاصيل انا اعطيك ما يتردد هنا في اوروبا
لان الضفه الاخرى من المحيط الاطلس هنا
الولايات المتحده ضمنت لنفسها نوع من
الاكتفاء الذاتي في مجال الطاقه وبالتالي
هي الان تسعى لتوسيع مصالحها بشكل اكبر
ولكن دون ان تبالي با الحلفاء الاوروبيين
باعتبار النهائيه في مناى عن هذه الازمه
التي تعيشها مثلا ستعيشها دوله مثل
المانيا
صحيح الولايات المتحده لن تشعر بهذا الضغط
الكبير في موضوع الطاقه كالذي تشعر به
الدول الاوروبيه وخصوصا الدول التي كانت
تعتمد بشكل كبير على استيراد الغاز الروسي
ولذلك انا اتفق مع وجهه نظر واشنطن بان
الاتحاد الاوروبي كان يجب ان يبحث عن
بدائل منذ الفتره طويله وان لا يثق
بالامتدادات الغاز الروسيه لانه يمكن ان
تستخدم في سلاح في لحظه ما الان اذا نظرنا
الى الاداره الامريكيه وما الذي يمكن ان
تفعله انا شخصيا اوافق بشكل كبير على ان
تقوم بدعم الحلفاء في اوروبا ولكن ايضا
هناك النقطه الداخليه التي اشار لها
الزميلين بشكل متكرر وهي نقطه صائبه جدا
بان في النهايه الاداره الامريكيه منتخبه
من الناخبين الامريكيين وتضع مصلحتهم اولا
وطبعا في حال كان هناك اي مزيد من
الضغوطات الاقتصاديه هذا يعني بان بايضا
وغيره من السياسيين المنتخبين لن ينتخبوا
مره اخرى وسيخسروا وظائفهم وهم بلا شك لا
يريدون ان يصلوا الى هذه النتيجه الان اين
سيتم رسم الخط بكم تقوم الولايات المتحده
بدعم حلفائها الاوروبيين وبكم يتحمل
الحلفاء الاوروبيون هذه الفاتوره اعتقد ان
هذا احد النقاشات الاساسيه بين الطرفين
هناك تحالف لاعود الى النقطه التي بدانا
فيها انا بان هناك تحالف بين الطرفين ولكن
خصوصا عندما نتحدث عن تحالفات بين دول
ديموقراطيه دائما هذه التحالفات كثيرا ما
تتعرض للاهتزاز لانها تمثل مصالحها
الداخليه والمصالح الداخليه دائما هناك
اختلافات كبيره وجمه واتفق بان الفتره
المقبل الى على الاغلب سنجد بان هذه
الخلافات تطفو الى السطح اكثر بين اكثر
بين الاوروبي والامريكي خصوصا عندما تصل
الى الموضوع الاقتصادي لانه اكبر ما يشعر
بها الناس على الارض هو المواط والناخبين
وهو دائما ما يؤثر الراي العام ليس فقط في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او لنقل
الاستماع الى المصلحه الدقيقه ليصف
الولايات المتحده يعني احنا لدينا حكومه
في ايطاليا حكومه دراعي سقطت بصير باب
الحرب الاوكرانيه هناك تخوف كبير من تنامي
اليمين المتطرف في المانيا تطالب بخروج
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه فهناك تكلفه
ليس فقط اقتصاديه هناك تكلفه سياسيه يعني
في النهايه هذه اوروبا التي بنيت على اسس
الديمقراطيه على التناوب الى غير ذلك هناك
الان احزاب سياسيه تقول ان الحكومات
الحاليه الان فشلت في اداره الصراع في
اوكرانيا فشلت في تامين الكود اليومي فشلت
كذلك في وقت التضخم من غير ذلك والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مطالبه ليس فقط ان تنظر
الى مصلحه الناخب الامريكي وكذا
وتوازن القوى داخل الولايات المتحده لكن
لدينا هناك في اوروبا مشكله كبيره
الان هناك الان ونقطه اليها همم تحدثت
فيها معك قبل البرنامج مساله القيم نعم
هناك صراع من اجل القيم يعني هناك حرب غير
معلنه بين روسيا من جهه والغرب من جهه
اخرى من يدافع عن القيم الضروريه
للانسانيه وراين ذلك في قمه العشرين وحتى
قبل قمه العشرين حصلت قمه للاديان للذره
الاولى بطلب من الولايات المتحده صحيح
يعني يعني القمه المخصصه للاديان يعني منذ
سنوات لكن الجديد فيها في ما حصل في
اندونيسيا مهم جدا قبل كل شيء لاندونيس
دوله مسلمه ثم رعت هذا الاجتماع مع منظمه
دولي اخرى رابط العالم الاسلامي مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه التي رقصت قمه
العشرين في فتره الكوفيت وهذه المره اعتقد
المقارنه الجديده هي كيف يمكن تاسيس في
النهايه همم تاسيس يعني قمه الاديان اما
هذا المجموعه ال 20 من اجل طرح قضايا
قضايا القيميه القضايا الدينيه القضايا
الروحيه لمنع اول الحروب المساهمه في حل
النزاعات لماذا لان دول الغربيه اعتقد
ربما معاها هكذا بعض الدول الاسلاميه بان
روسيا تستغل هذه النقطه قضيه ال- ال-
الاسره كقيمه ملجا الدين ان هذه الحرب
الاوكرانيه فما تقوم بروسيا وفي النهايه
يوم النزع الخروج من الشيطنه اوكرانيا
الخره من هؤلاء الذين لا يريدون في
النهايه همم الاستقامه او الخروج من عالم
الدين اعتقد ان اول مره تقول الغربيه
تفطنت الى قضيه القيم وانه الرئيس بوتين
استغل الدينمو صحيح
وجماعات دينيه يعني ما قام به كديروف
اجتماعات الدينيه اصبحت تجنب الجنود الروس
تحت مسميات دينيه والزش بهم في اوكرانيا
تحت مسمى ان الارثوذكسيه الحقيقيه التي
تدافع عنها بطريقيه روسيا هي مهدده في
اوكرانيا ولا الدول الغربيه التي تحارب
روسيا هي فنانه في النهايه اريد الدين
ولذلك هذه المبادره مهمه وخطيره جدا لان
في نهايه تريد ان تقول ان يجب ان بين
الدين والسياسه وان القيم الروحيه والقيم
الدينيه يجب ان تكون بالعكس اساس او وسيله
نحو الذهاب نحو مجتمع مسالم وان الاديان
خلقت من اجل ان تتعايش وليس لان تكون حطبا
او وقودا لاي حرب ما مقبله يعني ما نريد
ان نقوله يجب ان هذه المبادره تتكرر في
نهائي لان هذا ما بقي من يعني من امل
وفرنسا وكل الدول لاول مره يعني تصور انه
رئاسه مجموعه العشرين هي اندونيسيا وافقت
على هذا الاقتراح بموافقه كل الاعضاء بما
فيهم روسيا لانها رات فعلا بان هذه القضيه
بين قضيه هم هي قضيه
اريد اريد رايكم في هذه الموضوع لانك
بالفعل الان هناك تفطر لهذه الظاهره لانها
هناك من يراها خطيره في حال كل طرف يسوق
لانه هو الذي يحتكر القيام القيام التي
يجب ان تتمتع بها الى الانسانيه
يعني دائما الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
عندما ياتي الموضوع الى القيم هناك
تناقضات كبيره وجمع معروفه للجميع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من جهه تدافع
عن القيم الليبراليات تدافع القيم
العلمانيه تدافع عن حقوق الانسان من جهه
اخرى كثيره ما تحالفت مع انظمه
الديكتاتوريه ودعمت اجهزه مخابراتها
الكثير من الانقلابات حول العالم والكثير
منها طبعا كان في قاره امريكا اللاتينيه
حيث دعمت حكومات عسكريه ارتكبت الكثير من
جرائم حقوق الانسان اثناء الحرب البارده
لمنع اليسار او منع الشيوعيين من الوصول
الى الحكم ولكن بالمقابل ايضا لنعطي
الصوره الكامنه الولايات المتحده ايضا
دافعت كثيرا عن حقوق الانسان وقامت بتمويل
الكثير من البرامج حول العالم ولكن تاتي
المشكله عندما يتعرض الامن القومي
الامريكي لان يكون المنفعه الانيه هي
مغيره للقيام التي تدافع عنها الولايات
المتحده
امريكيه وكثيره ارتكبت اخطاء جم لن يغفر
لها التاريخ ومعروفه لدى الجميع ولكنك لا
نتحدث عن الماضي نتحدث الان عما يجري
اليوم اتفق كثيرا مع الضيف من الاستديو
الذي تحدث عن معركه القيم بين روسيا وبين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه روسيا الان هي
ايضا في تناقض كبير للقيم التي تدعيها من
ضمنها قيم العلمانيه وفصل الدين عن الدوله
بوتن استغل الدين ليس فقط في اوكرانيا
ايضا في سوريا نذكر الصور الكاهن
والبطريرك الروسي وهو يبارك الطائرات
الروسيه التي خرجت وقصفت قتلت المدنيين في
سوريا من الضروري جدا مناقشه هذه المواضيع
من الضروري جدا ان لا يتم تجاهلها وخصوصا
اذا ما ادخلنا الى هذا همم النقاش موضوع
اندونيسيا وموضوع المحيط الهادئ في الصراع
مع الصين لان هذه نقطه مهمه جدا وعامل
هيكون كبير في الصراع مع الصين لان هو
ايضا عامل صحيح انه صراع امني وصراع
اقتصادي بالاساس ولكنه ايضا صراع للقيم
والصراع على شكل النظام العالمي وكيف
سيكون او ما هي القيم التي سيقوم عليها
بالنسبه لموضوع القيم الدول الاوروبيه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه تحاول تسويق
القيم التي لديها بشتى السبل هناك معارضه
من بعض الدول لوجود عادات وتقاليد لاختلاف
الدين لاختلاف
همم نتحدث عن روسيا بشكل خاص هي هم
والاوكرانيون وهم على ديانا واحدهم بالاصل
على اخوه اسلاميين بالاصل الاتحاد
الاوروبي يرى بان روسيا الاتحاد الاوروبي
يريد روسيا ارى ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
يتعامل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بمكيالين اللي ناخذ مثالا همم قريب جدا من
قطر وهو ما وهو متحدث عنه الكثير يمكن
الصحف الغربيه وبالاخص في المانيا
عشان هجوما لاذعا على قطر وعلى جميع مناحي
الحياه في قطر وعلى مجتمع الميم و و و و
وبالامس تم توقيع اتفاقيه غاز ما بين قطر
وما بين المانيا تستورد به الالمانيه 15
عاما من الغاز القطري اذا هناك بعض التميز
بين العلاقه العلاقه الاقتصاديه اي ما يهم
نساء ياخذوا من اي دوله سواء كانت
الديكتاتوريه سواء كانت غير ديكتاتوريه او
سواء كانت تلك الدوله مائيه في القيم او
هي ديمقراطيه او غير ديموقراطيه عند
الحديث على موضوع اخر لا يموت باقتصادي
انا كشخص المانيا او بالحكومه الالمانيه
فقطر عباره عن دوله لا تهتم بحقوق الانسان
لا تهتم بحقوق العاملين وغير ذلك وهذا هو
وهذا هو ما يسمى بالكيل لا يجب على احد ان
يفرض قيمه وحقوقه وحورياته على دوله اخرى
لكل دوله لكل شعب الحريه في اختيار ما
يريده
في عام 1966 عندما اقيم كاس العالم في
انجلترا لم يكن هناك حقوق للمثليين وكانت
محرمه في عام 1966 اي ان هناك تطور في
المجتمعات الغربيه وتم قبول المجتمع
المثليه هناك دول في اوروبا اصلا في
اوروبا الشرقيه كهنغاريا كمولندا تشيك
ترفض موضوع المثليه اذا هناك تناقض في
الاتحاد الاوروبي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في تسويقها لما مفهوم حريه
الانسان حقوق الانسان وما او حريه الديانه
وما الى ذلك لذلك ارى ان الدول الاوروبيه
يزم التلتزم الصمت داخليا وان تروج مثل
هذه الحقوق مواضيع اخرى ليس بموضوع
الارغام تلك الدوله
يعني الغربه
يعني هناك حكومات يعني تعنى بمصالحها لكن
هناك مجتمع مدني يطالب باحترام حقوق
الانسان يحتار بحقوق الاقليات ولا يوجد
هناك تناقض يعني في قضيه اجتماع اندونيسيا
ار تونتي وجيت وانت الشيء الايجابي هو انه
التحالف جمعيه علماء مسلميه ونهضه علماء
اندونيسيا مع رابط عالم الاسلامي وبناء في
النهايه بجسور فيها باحثين سياسيين
اجتماعين هو قبل كل شيء فضح الاستعمال او
الاستعمال السياسي توظيف الدين في مسائل
تخص بالامن العالمي سواء الحرب والسلام
وان اخته مهمه كما عان العالم الاسلامي
باستعمال كذلك الدين في حروب وفي مشاكل
ادت بنا في النهايه الى مازق حروب اهليه
فلي اول مره هناك انتباه الى ان احد كذلك
حتى الحروب الدوليه الحروب الاقليميه ما
يقع في اوكرانيا يجب ان لا يزج بالدين يجب
ان لا يستعمل بالدين وان تكون هناك يعني
جسور اخرى من قبل المجتمعات المدنيه من
قبل المدنيين ولا امريكيين في هذا المجال
في هذا يعني هناك الان يعني بدايه وعي من
قبل الولايات المتحده الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه دوله سباقه تتذكر كل ووزاره
الخارجيه تعمل تقرير خاص بالحريات الدينيه
هذه المره انتبهوا خاصه في خطاب بوتين
الاخير عندما تحدث عن المثليين وتحدث على
ما على الممارسات الغربيه التي يريد الغرب
يريد ان يفرضها على روسيا وعلى الدول
الافريقيه وتحدث حتى على الدول الاسلاميه
الى غير ذلك فهنا تفطن الغرب ان قضيه
القيم الروحيه والقيم الدينيه هي سلاح يجب
ان لا تكون محتكره فقط على دوله باعتبار
ان روسيا تسوق نفسها بانها تحمي القيمه
الملجا القيمه الاسره والدين الى غير ذلك
فالمشكله انا اعتقد كذلك انه يجب لانه في
العلاقات الدوليه من العلاقات الدوليه في
النهايه لا تعرف اخلاق وانما فقط مصالح
لكن لا يمكن كذلك ان يكون هناك احترام مثل
ما استطاعه المنظمه الصليب الاحمر الدولي
ان تصنع قانون الدول الانساني لاحترام في
النهايه المدنيين فكذلك احد اعتقد انه
يمكن كذلك القيم الدينيه والقيم الروحيه
السماويه ان تكون من اجل ان ان لا تنتشر
الحروب هو على الاقل من اجل ان همم تفقد
شرعيه الدين في الاستعمال السياسي ابراهيم
الاصيل يعني حتى الان المبادئ لا تقسم
المبادئ المبادئ لا تقسم هناك شركات
المانيه عملت في سداد قطر وعملت مع هؤلاء
العاملين الذين لم يكن لديهم اي حقوق في
قطر هناك شركات فرنسيه وهناك شركات
بريطانيه اشتغلت في قطر وجدت الكثير من
الاموال المبادئ يجب ان لا تقسم تلك
الدوله ليس لديها اي حقوق الانسان تمنع
هذه الشركات من الذهاب ليس لان المصلحه
العليا هي المصلحه الاقتصاديه ثم نتحدث عن
القيم ثم نتحدث عن العادات والعرف والدين
هذه المشكله لدى الغرب هو اننا عندما نريد
ان ناخذ اي شيء اقتصادي فنرحب بالجميع
وعندما
تحدث هناك اي مشكله بسبب ما وانا سنتحدث
عن المانيا بشكل خاص هذا الهجوم المانيا
على قطر انما لنلفظ قطر تس- ايصال الغاز
الى المانيا لمده عامين دائما قطر ترغب
بان يكون هناك عقود غاز لمده تزيد عن 10
سنوات او 15 عاما ومنذ شهر اربعه منذ شهر
ابريل هذا الحالي والالمان يحاولون لشراء
الغاز من قطر وقطر ترفض بيع الغاز الا
بعقود طويله الاجل ومن هنا كانت الحمله
الالمانيه ضد قطر بشكل عام اذا نعود الى
المبدا الواحد ان المبادئ يجب ان لا تتقسم
مبدئي واحد يجب على استمر عليه بغض النظر
سواء كان موضوع اقتصادي او سياسي
من مبادئ يعني في المانيا لديها جمعيات
حقوقيه لديها نقبات تطالب باحترام حقوق
العمال والعقليات في نفس الوقت لديه حكومه
هي مهمتها تامين الغاز
يعني لا ارى اين هو تاثير قطر كبير
نعم لماذا طب ممكن ممكن السؤال بس لماذا
لم لماذا لم يبقي الاتحاد الاوروبي خط
السيل الشمالي والخطوط الغاز القادمه من
روسيا وهذا مهم للاقتصاد الاوروبي هو مهم
للمواطن الالماني نحن ندفع الان بدايه من
شهر اثنان من شهر ديسمبر من يومي غدا ندفع
اكثر من 15% على فواتير الكهرباء لماذا لم
يهتم اسس الاوروبيون بهذا الموضوع ونشتري
الغاز من قطع من روسيا باستعار بخور ويكون
الصناعه والدائره الاقتصاديه ممتازه ولا
نتحدث عن ذلك الا عندما نتحدث عن مبادئ عن
المبادئ هي مقسمه والمانيا
ابراهيم الاصيل يعني رغم كل هذه
الاجتماعات وكل هذه اللقاءات وكل هذه
المشاركات ولكن عندما نرى الوضع على الارض
في اوكرانيا الامور تراوح مكانها
الامور حاليا ااه تراوح مكانها لانها ربما
وصلت الى شيء من التكافؤ بين الطرفين وهذا
عامل مهم لانه عندما تراوح الامور مكانها
عاده في الصراعات العسكريه هذا عامل مهم
لينضج
لتصبح المفاوضات ممكنه لانه اذا ما كان
احد الطرفين ما يزال يستطيع ان يحقق
انتصارات عسكريه متتاليه على الارض هذا
يعني بان المفاوضات لا مكان لها الا اذا
استسلم الطرف الاخر ولكن هذا التوازن الذي
نراه الان ربما يساعد على ان ننتقل نوعا
ما الى بدء بجولات مفاوضات طبعا ست تاخذ
وقتا طويلا جدا لان هذا الصراع عميق همم
بشكل كبير اقتصادي وقيمي وعسكري وامني
ولكن على الاقل ربما يساعد ذلك الان الى
ان اتجه الى موضوع المفاوضات بخصوص بعض
النقط التي
برنامج
اختار نقطه واحده فقط عنها هو موضوع
النقطه التي اشارتها انت اليها الحكومات
متى تضع القيم او حقوق الانسان في
اولوياتها وهذا نقاش طبعا فلسفي مهم جدا
ال- ال- النظريه السياسيه الواقعيه ترى
بان الحكومات يجب ان لا تهتم بحقوق
الانسان وتهتم فقط باملها القومي سواء كان
عسكريا امنيا او اقتصاديا ولكن ايضا هناك
راي اخر ليبرالي وهو يرى بانه
حلقه توفيق
فلسفيه فلسفيه
في جميع الجنابه الشكر ياسين وهو كاتب
صحفي والشكر لابراهيم الاصيل الكبير
الباحثين في معهد الشرق الاوسط في واسطوان
الشكر لفريق البرنامج امس يا مريحه للجميع